in its origins a liberal education
always had science in it though
interestingly people studied science in
ancient Greece and Rome in the Middle
Ages until very recently for precisely
the opposite reason that people are now
told to study it we are now told you
should study it because it's a practical
skill that you can use in the real world
well in ancient Greece the practical
skills that got you jobs and got you a
career were rhetoric and oratory and a
study of history and law science was
seen as a kind of abstract quest for
knowledge the only reason you were doing
it was mental stimulation and yet for
hundreds and hundreds of years people
studied science really just to try to
answer the big questions there was no
sense that it could be applied in a way
that was practical would provide you
with a career that's a very modern
conception of science and so I think
what's interesting is that even then
when we thought science was useless we
studied it useless in a practical sense
today my argument will be you know think
about that length and breadth of history
and when you say that English is useless
Yale has opened a campus in Singapore
and what they've done is they've tried
to reimagine what a liberal education
would look like and they've also tried
to reimagine what it would look like in
a global context there is a core that
for the first two years there is a
series of required courses but the
requirements are more in method of
inquiry that is in critical thinking
rather than in a particular subject or a
particular set of books you study
Aristotle but at the same time you read
Confucius who was Aristotle's
contemporary and you ask yourself why
did Aristotle have certain concerns
about politics but Confucius had others
what explains this difference so the
idea here would be to try to understand
that the West is not the only thing in
the world that there is a much broader
universe and you understand the
differences in similarities all these
subjects have deep long traditions and
feed various parts of the human brain
and the human soul and so recognize that
what seems fashionable when one ERA will
not seem fashionable in another but they
all
together interact and comprise a liberal
education